SMP spokesperson Stephen Flynn yeah
thank you Mr Speaker if the Prime
Minister was to go to the boot of his
Land Rover and pull out some placards
which said save our nomdoms which he
expect to be arrested by the police
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
can I first put on record my thanks to
the police for all their hard work over
the weekend ensuring that the coronation
was a success now look on this issue Mr
Speaker we believe the police should
have powers to make sure that they can
protect the public from unnecessary and
serious disruption I respectfully
recognize that The Honorable gentleman
disagrees with our position I guess the
question for both of us is what does the
honorable
can I just remind the Prime Minister his
prime minister's questions maybe to
answer no asking God not for what the
oppositions do is Stephen Flynn
Mr Mr Speaker what we're talking about
here is the nurses strike doctors strike
firefighters strike Republic protest
firefighters protest and of course of
course Republicans protest as well and
you do so because it's a fundamental
right within our democracy to be able to
protest so as a prime minister seriously
saying that moving forward you can have
your rights but only on his terms
well Mr Speaker it is also the right of
the British public to be able to go
about their ordinary day-to-day lives
without undue serious disruption that's
why it's right that the police have
extra Powers I suspect that The
Honorable gentleman disagrees with that
but we think it is right and but people
will see every day every day on TV their
lives being disrupted they're not able
to get to school to get to hospital
appointments and indeed to get to work
they should be able to do that and the
police should have powers to stop those
who are preventing that from happening